[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans le débrief
du doc cette fois nous allons parler du
documentaire sos bébés phoques tournée
en russie il s'intéresse à une espèce
menacée le phoque du groenland
ces mammifères marins font face à
plusieurs défis le changement climatique
mais aussi la chasse à des fins
commerciales ou traditionnelle à travers
cet exemple ce documentaire pose une
question cruciale comment combiner la
préservation des espèces animales et
l'activité humaine l'homme doit-il
cesser certaines pratiques
traditionnelles pour en parler avec nous
sami hassani expert en mammifères marins
rattaché à la direction scientifique
d'océanopolis et directeur de
l'association pour la conservation des
mammifères marins et oiseaux de bretagne
sami hassani bonjour bonjour merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france
ce documentaire vous l'avez regardé
plusieurs fois le phoque du groenland il
y est décrit comme un animal mystérieux
y at il de si particulier
alors je sais pas si les plus mystérieux
qu'une autre espèce en tout cas bon
comme pour la plupart des espèces
arctique c'est des animaux qui sont
difficiles d'approché qui vivent dans un
environnement difficile est rude mais il
n'y a pas de mystère pour tout cela
qu'on reconnaît bien la biologie de
l'espèce
c'est une espèce comme une autre de
l'arctique et comme les autres espèces
de l'article enfin d autres femmes qui
vivent en article
ce qu'il y a de particulier cette espèce
est plus tout
l'aspect autour des blanches en de ces
jeunes phoques aux plages tout blanc
où il ya beaucoup d'émotion chez le
public de voir ces jeunes c'est le jeune
phoque qui ressemblent à des peluches
mais en réalité c'est un carnivore
rendre ces documents terre nous apprend
aussi qu'un il est très difficile de
recenser la population de phoques du
groenland pour coiffer si difficile
alors c'est difficile même titre que
celle et pour d'autres espèces qu'une
répartition très vaste le phoque du
groenland
c'est une espèce qui répartit on va dire
depuis le le canada
antic nord-est jusqu'au repas sans temps
mort landes la norvège et puis jusqu'en
vers blanche en russie donc c'est un
territoire très vaste on artix à une
espèce qui
fonctionne de la banquise et les plaques
de glace dérivantes et donc pour arriver
a estimé
l'abondance de ces de cette espèce il
faut des moyens considérables
donc il ya des recensements qui se font
par
[Musique]
avion d'autres qui se font depuis la
terre et donc c'est ce qui compte
compliquer les choses et puis il ya
plusieurs pays qui sont concernés
donc afin d'homogénéiser et d'avoir à un
moment donné une image puisque et la
population c'est extrêmement compliqué
on a surtout des estimations quoi
sachant qu'en plus ces opérations se
font tous les deux 5 ans 6 ans et donc
on n'a pas une image réelle de l'état
des populations on a quand même une idée
on sait aujourd'hui l'affiché les
phoques arctique la plus abondante et
même chez les phoques en général la plus
abondante on a mis ce dernier oui en
arctique oui on estime que le les
phoques du groenland avoisine
aujourd'hui les 7 millions d'individus
alors l'iucn vous savez l'union
internationale pour la conservation de
la nature un système de classification
des espèces en fonction d'un pas mal de
critères et donc il ya
ensuite on arrive donc on mixe tous ces
critères on casse l'espèce ont des temps
soit en danger soit vulnérable soit aux
critiques critique d'extinction ou aux
préoccupation mineure pour le phoque du
groenland aujourd'hui
les spécialistes et comme on
préoccupation mineure par rapport
justement à l'abondance de l'espace qui
est autour de 7 millions d'individus qui
était plus importante sans doute avant
la chasse commerciale on estime qu'avant
la chasse commerciale avant on va dire
la deuxième guerre mondiale puisque
c'est là que ça s'est intensifié après
deuxième guerre mondiale on était
peut-être autour de 2 millions pour
cette espèce alors aujourd'hui vous
parler de la chasse il ya 35 ans qui ont
interdit l'importation de produits à
partir de phoques ou la chasse donc aux
blancs font les bébés phoques
est ce que cette décision a eu un impact
sur la population de phoques du
groenland
immédiatement je sais pas si ça eu un
impact mais en tout cas il est certain
qu'aujourd'hui avec cette interdition de
notamment celles europe 1 en 2010 ce qui
a interdit l'importation de produits
dérivés à partir de fuck
évidemment bien sûr ça ralentit la
chasse mais il ya pas que ça il ya aussi
les mentalités qui ont évolué dans pas
mal de pays aujourd'hui
ethiquement il ya beaucoup de personnes
qui n'acceptent plus ces scènes de
chasse même si beaucoup de pays ont
interdit la chasse aux blanchons des
continue parfois de chasser un peu du
phoque du groenland donc c'est un impact
mais ce qu'il doit faire face ces
espèces en arctique c'est plus le
changement climatique et la régression
de la banquise qui peut être un sérieux
problème pour ces espèces qui utilisent
la banquise pour la mise bas et donc si
elles ne sont pas capables de trouver
d'autres sites pour mettre bas ça risque
de compromettre la dynamique de la
population sachant que par ailleurs le
réchauffement en arctique a aussi des
répercussions sur les espèces présentes
et en particulier les espèces trois
pour les femmes alors concernant la
chasse sont des décisions qui ne
plaisent pas à tout le monde même à
certains scientifiques on a pu le voir
dans le documentaire regarder
les peau des phoques de moins d'un an
des raisons était toujours très prisée
en urss on a inventé un moyen spécial de
les chasser les blanchons vivant été
recueillis dans les filets et
transportés en hélicoptère dans des
enclos spéciaux que plus tard les
écologistes ont nommé camps de
concentration
[Musique]
les phoques étaient élevées jusqu'à ce
qu'ils deviennent gris et ensuite abattu
les petits n'était pas nourri parce
qu'ils avaient assez de graisse sous
cutanée pour tenir deux à trois semaines
les partisans de la reprise de la chasse
conviennent que la pratique des enclos
est très rentable mais alors ils sont
prêt à la reprendre
[Musique]
nasri est légué un chouette il faut
autoriser les enclos pour blanche ont à
nouveau pour les laisser devenir adulte
et puis chassés ces phoques là comme on
le faisait traditionnellement
ses méthodes n'ont pas surgi de nulle
part
en union soviétique
la rentabilité était très bien calculé
cette méthode elle se justifie
la norvège notre partenaire le plus
proche continue parfaitement à chasser à
vendre des phoques vous pouvez aller
dans les commerces en norvège et voir le
prix et vous comprendrez combien peut
gagner une personne qui travaille dans
ce domaine
sami hassani comment vous réagissez à
ces arguments
il ya plusieurs choses là dedans
d'abord là aussi équipements
c'est pas très acceptable
d'autre part ce qui n'est pas 10 parce
que 10 pas la personne c'est que
c'est cette pratique ces pratiques de
l'union soviétique c'étaient des choses
qui étaient très subventionnés et z
aujourd'hui on sait très bien que c'est
pas rentable
c'est beaucoup plus lucratif de
développer un éco tourisme responsable
plutôt que de subventionner des chasses
pour lesquels il ya très peu de marché
aujourd'hui après moi je peux comprendre
que moi je fais la part entre une chasse
commerciale et puis des chasse de
subsistance comme on peut avoir chez les
inuit owen landes ou dans le nunavut au
canada ces deux choses différentes
c'est des pratiques d'abord ancestrale
chez les inuit ils en vivent ici on
alimente alors qu'on veut si c'est
quelque chose qui a été développée à
grande échelle à des fins très
commercial et puis aujourd'hui la
demande en fourrure n'existe quasiment
plus
il ya très peu de gens qui s'alimentent
de viande de phoque si ce n'est un peu
au canada en norvège comme ça a été dit
ou mais plus intensément et de manière
plus traditionnelle chez les inuits ou
d'autres peuples du nord qui on peut
retrouver également en russie justement
vous parlez du canada c'est le pays qui
en tête des chasseurs de phoques en 2019
ce pays a fixé un seuil pouvant aller
jusqu'à 400 mille individus prélevés par
an ça vous paraît énorme ça paraît
énorme comme ça bon on regarde de l'état
de la population non si je me place en
tant que biologiste
qu'on peut le faire s'ils ont des quotas
de pêche sur d'autres espèces marines
mais il faut savoir que compte tenu des
menaces qu'il ya sur cette espèce par
rapport aux changements climatiques pas
contenu t débouché commercial ça n'a
plus grand intérêt de le faire sachant
que en plus au canada avec la baisse de
la banquise même si il ya des quotas
élevés qui ont été attribués je crois
que ce qui est réellement chasse et bien
en-deça de ces chiffres là
je crois qu'en 2019 si je me ça reste à
vérifier mais je crois que sur les
quotas attribués et peut-être que trente
ou quarante mille phoques de chasse et
parce que la glace n'était pas
suffisamment épaisse y avait pas assez
de phoque et pas d'accès
aux phoques du groenland pour les
chasser donc on voit bien que
c'est plus soutenable comme
économiquement comme pratique quoi à
cette échelle là en tout cas
alors vous dites que ça n'a plus
vraiment d'intérêt économique il n'y a
pas que le canada qui autorise encore la
chasse au phoque ya aussi la namibie la
norvège
comment expliquer que ça paye s'accroche
à fait pratique alors je pense qu'il ya
plusieurs choses alors il ya les
chasseurs qu'on a incité pendant des
années à chasser donc on leur a fourni
des débouchés économiques et un travail
et que aujourd'hui leur dire on arrête
tous pour eux c'est leur enlever de la
bouche mais comme je disais tout à
l'heure il faudrait accompagner ces
populations-là à des reconversions et
notamment des reconversions vers
l'écotourisme on sait aujourd'hui pour
d'autres d'autres espèces
10 langues en islande par exemple sur la
baleine c'est devenu plus lucratifs
d'amener des touristes observer les
baleines plutôt que les chasser de les
vendre après ces pratiques là il faut
bien les encadrer parce qu'elles peuvent
être aussi avoir des impacts négatifs
sur ces populations de l'anonymat dans
le documentaire on rencontre aussi
d'anciens chasseurs qui sont aujourd'hui
à priver de cette activité
il légitime le retour à la chasse aux
phoques en l'accusant de nuire à
d'autres espèces regardez
en raison des restrictions la population
de phoques se reconstituent
et les poissons en souffre et ainsi que
les habitants locaux un phoque a besoin
de 20 kg de poissons par jour pour se
nourrir
quand et combien il y en a dans la mer
actuellement
[Musique]
habile au coach s'amuse vous avez vu des
blanchons ils sont comme des enfants
avec leurs grands yeux larmoyants c'est
très dur psychologiquement
[Musique]
mais quel autre emploi peut-on trouver
ici
comme la chasse est leur gagne pain et
depuis qu'ils ont cessé de les chasser
il n'ya plus de poisson
regardez combien il l'a de phoques ici
ici il y en a plein ici au togo
[Musique]
ils abîment les filets et dévore les
poissons l'année dernière a été un
désastre pour les pêcheurs locaux alors
est ce que c'est vrai est ce que le
phoque un responsable d'une diminution
des réserves de poissons c'est quelque
chose qu'on entend et c'est des
préoccupations qui sont d'actualité
puisqu'il n'y a pas que la russie ou
le montre le reportage où on accuse les
phoques de la réaction des ressources
c'est beaucoup plus complexe que ça le
fuck comme les autres mammifères marins
et comme d'autres compétiteurs sont
plutôt des indicateurs de la qualité des
milieux c'est à dire que si encore du
phoque et si tu multiplies c'est parce
qu'ils y trouvent de quoi s'alimenter
après s'alimente pas forcément des
ressources exploitées par l'homme pas
que en tout cas et ce qui a été dit dans
le reportage
la femme n'a parlé de 20 kg par jour
en réalité c'est pas ça c'est quelque
chose quand mon temps ou le phoque
manche son propre repas par jour un
phoque a besoin des besoins énergétiques
qui font qu'il a besoin en gros 2 4% 4 5
% de sa masse corporel par jour donc en
fait 200 kg arabe des besoins autour de
4 à 5 kg de poissons et les prédateurs
supérieurs comme les phoques sont plutôt
des régulateurs des écosystèmes et on a
déséquilibré ces écosystèmes soit par
des chasses sur ces espèces la soie par
des pêches intensives sur des ressources
poisson le cas de la morue de
terre-neuve par exemple est un exemple
ou dans ma on a épuisé les stocks de
morue et malgré le moratoire bah ça
remonte pas donc c'est plutôt l'homme
qui responsables des déséquilibres
insiste m bien équilibrée laisse de la
place pour tout le monde et donc un
système équilibré c'est lequel dans
lequel on va retrouver depuis les
espèces planctoniques jusqu aux
prédateurs supérieurs merci famille
fanny nous marquons une courte pause
nous nous retrouvons dans quelques
minutes pour continuer à débriefer le
documentaire sos bébés phoques sur rt
france a tout de suite
[Musique]
le documentaire sos bébés phoques on
continue d'en parler avec notre invité
sami hassani directeur de l'association
pour la conservation des mammifères
marins et oiseaux de bretagne et expert
en mammifères marins rattaché à la
direction scientifique d'océanopolis de
brest donc on en a parlé en début
d'émission malgré plusieurs
interdictions la chasse contribue à la
disparition des phoques du groenland
justement pour changer de braquet et
tenter de concilier le développement
économique et la sauvegarde des phoques
certains villages en russie lance
d'autres activités autour de cet animal
regardez l'écotourisme a commencé à se
développer à l'etna liasse de l'autize à
cet afflux de touristes pourrait attirer
l'attention sur le problème de
l'extinction des phoques du groenland
lna et olga ont parcouru la moitié de la
planète elles sont difficiles à
impressionner mais toutes deux estime
que c'est ici dans le parc national de
neige cueilli peau mourier qu'elles
verront un véritable miracle aujourd'hui
oui nous espérons assister au miracle
d'une nouvelle vie à la naissance de
petits phoques les bébés phoques blanc
tout mignon et du foot sur la banquise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on ne peut rejoindre les phoques qu'en
hélicoptère
il est difficile de prédire où on les
trouvera nous comptons sur notre
intuition et notre expérience
[Musique]
les écotouristes en eu de la chance
après 1h30 de vol ils ont finalement pu
voir trois bébés phoques et leur mère
sur la banquise
sami hassani vous nous en parliez tout à
l'heure de l'écotourisme comme une
solution
pour que l'homme continuer à préserver
et à cohabiter est ce que c'est une
solution sans risque alors c'est une
solution qui n'est pas sans risque
effectivement parce que nés qu'autorise
mal encadré peut avoir des effets
néfastes
notamment le dérangement ces espèces et
notamment le dérangement pendant des
périodes critiques de leur cycle de vie
en particulier la mise bas et
l'allaitement qui est quelque chose de
très courts quant à savoir quelle faute
du grand nombre ces deux semaines donc
si le couple mère jeune et dérangé à ce
moment là bas c'est une mortalité chez
les jeunes et donc ça aurait l'effet
inverse donc pour cela et c'est le cas
pour d'autres activités d'écotourisme
je vais parler que de mammifères marins
ou par exemple le whale watching ou le
dolfjin watching des mots anglais enfin
ce qu'il veut dire l'observation de ces
mammifères marins en mer sont
aujourd'hui dans pas mal de pays très
encadrée soit par des chartes des codes
de conduite voire des réglementations
donc il faut que ça soit bien encadré
ces activités là pour ne pas avoir un
effet négatif vous ne parliez aussi tout
à l'heure du changement climatique car
l'impact sur sur cette espèce
concrètement comment comment quel impact
a directement le changement climatique
et le changement climatique dans ces
contrées en arctique celle à la baisse
de l'épaisseur de la banquise c'est la
régression de la surface de la banquise
or les espèce arctique à l'effort
arctique utilisent cette banquise pour
la mise bas et dont c'est une période
cruciale du cycle de vie de ces animaux
là et donc moins bons qu'ils épaisse
moins de banquise résistante une
banquise réduite en surface que c'est
moins de surface de mise bas et de
reposoir pour ces espèces et donc à
terme on ne sait pas comment ça peut
aller d'un cactées alors ça peut les
impacts et aussi il y en a beaucoup
moins à voir si elle disparaît après on
ne sait pas si ces espèces sont
suffisamment plastique pour au mieux de
se reproduire sur la banquise se
reproduire sur les estrans mais ce qui
les confronte à des prédateurs comme non
scolaires mais est-ce que l'ours polaire
est encore présent
c'est assez compliqué mais en tout cas
on le voit bien avec la régression de la
banquise et on voit aussi dans le
reportage puisque
parfois ils ont du mal à trouver ses
phoques du groenland qui utilise un
espace qui est très vaste mais ils sont
pas toujours présents au même endroit
alors c'est vrai que dans le reportage
handica raréfaction des phoques du
groenland en mer de barents
les celliers justement à la dérive de
ces plaques et comme je le disais tout à
l'heure le phoque du groenland n'est pas
une espèce menacée en soit pour
l'instant puisque ses effectifs sans
cobham c'est important mais en mer de
barents
le nombre de blanchot varie d'une année
à l'autre en fonction justement de la
dérive de ces plaques de glace et puis
de la disponibilité de cette banquise
donc il ya des saisons des années on va
avoir beaucoup et puis des années on va
on va beaucoup et on a l'impression que
l'espèce n'est plus là mais c'est vrai
qu'en plus c'est pas un air de bahreïn
s'est pas l'endroit du monde dans la
répartition de l'espèce où il ya plus
d'individus des fois qu'on n'observe pas
seulement dans les territoires que vous
venez de citer y en a aussi en france
notamment certaines dans la baie de
somme de 2 quelle espèce de fois qu'il
s'agit est ce qu elles sont elles aussi
menacées
alors les espèces que l'on a on bretagne
et en france il ya deux espèces il ya le
feu grillé puis el fogon marin et là
aussi c'est des espèces qu'ils ont été
chassés jusque dans les années 50 60 et
les colonies ont failli disparaître les
colonies ont disparu d'ailleurs
et c'est grâce à la protection de
l'espèce l'interdiction de chasser dans
un premier temps puis
la création de réserves lors de réserves
naturelles qui ont la plupart ont été
créés pour les oiseaux mais elles ont
bénéficié aux mammifères marins qui sont
ces phoques gris et veaux marins qui ont
retrouvé des zones refuges des havres de
paix et on assiste depuis les années 90
jusqu'à aujourd'hui à une augmentation
des populations mais elle reste
régionalement vulnérables
voilà on a quand même d'aider plus toute
petite colonie en france ont rien à voir
avec les effectifs dont on parlait tout
à l'heure du phoque du groenland
les phoques gris par exemple en france
il y en a peut-être un millier peut-être
un peu plus aujourd'hui
sachant que la population européenne est
au tour de son 200 mille individus on
n'est pas voilà on a vraiment des
petites populations mule ciel se portent
qu'un aujourd'hui que les ans une
dynamique positive il ya plus de chasse
en france le problème aujourd'hui en
france c'est plus éventuellement le
dérangement de cette espèce comme je le
disais tout à l'heure notamment pendant
le des périodes critiques du cycle de
vie que ce soit la venue ou non les
phoques change de plage ou au nom de l'
de la mise bas et de l'allaitement
c'est encore plus vrai pour le veau
marin le phoque veau marin donc on
retrouve surtout en picardie en baie de
somme on le trouve aussi en breton dans
la baie du mont saint michel
qui seront produits en été et donc on
était les plages et les sites sont assez
fréquentes et et le reste est ce
dérangement donc il ya des associations
et des gestionnaires de sites qui
travaille pour sensibiliser le public
sur le risque qu'il y aurait à
s'approcher trop trop de ses colonies et
de ces individus d'un contraint de se
reproduire est ce que à cause de la
demande de la fonte des glaces du
réchauffement climatique à ce qu'on
pourrait imaginer que le flop du
groënland migrent jusque chez son cousin
breton
je ne crois pas puisque c'est une espèce
arctique donc on peut s'attendre plutôt
à ce qu'elle remonte un peu plus au nord
rechercher des endroits où il ya encore
de la banquise encore des ressources
exploitables pour l'espèce
il est arrivé par le passé qu'on est des
individus isolés a un qu'on trouve
échoué en bretagne ou ailleurs en france
mais l'environnement n'est pas propice à
cette espèce laon termes de température
on va dire
oui tout à fait et en plus les ouvre en
atlantique se réchauffe même dans le
golfe de gascogne en bretagne les
ostrikov on a gagné un degré 5 jeux en
vingt ans donc c'est notre préoccupation
est ce que les espèces qu'on a local non
vont s'adapter pour l'instant elles sont
suffisamment plastique nous parle de 20
degrés mais si c'est plus ça peut
changer beaucoup de choses dans
l'environnement dans ce documentaire on
apprend aussi que c'est très difficile
de faire reproduire les facs en
laboratoire
on entend une scientifique qui a mené
l'expérience pourquoi pas si compliqué
alors c'est pas forcément aussi
compliqué il faut leur donner bien sûr
un environnement artificiel reconstitué
qui permet justement la reproduction
les deux espèces que l'on retrouve le
plus en captivité affaires présentées au
public dans des parcs zoologiques des
aquariums ça va être le phoque veau main
ou le faux grille donc ça fait très
longtemps que ces espèces ont été
acclimatées et ilir de la reproduction
et aujourd'hui les échanges entre les
parcs zoologiques et les équations qui
présente du phoque gris du vos mains se
fait uniquement à partir de naissance en
captivité donc ce n'est pas si compliqué
après pour des espèces article c'est
beaucoup plus complexe puisque ben quand
je disais tout à l'heure ça vit dans un
environnement très froid avec de la
glace des températures très basses et ça
pour reconstituer c'est cet
environnement c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué et puis il faut avoir des
espèces qui at-elle la maturité sexuelle
qui est suffisamment d'individus pour la
reproduction donc voilà je sais qu au
canada le fonds du groenland il ya c'est
un laboratoire de recherche d'ailleurs
qui est internet qui avait réussi à
reproduire en espèces
mais effectivement pour les espèces
arctique pour les espèces qui vivent
dans un environnement extrême eh bien il
faut arriver à constituer ses
environnements pour pouvoir donner
tous les conditions de vie pour ces
espèces là et ça c'est un peu plus
compliqué mais justement est ce que la
science pain à quelque chose pour faire
et fenêtres qui ferment a fait
la science ce qu'elle peut déjà c'est
étudié ces espèces mieux les connaître
et puis c'est des mesures de
conservation et protection donc des
mesures de gestion
qu'il faut mettre en place après on a
tous notre part de responsabilité
l'humanité responsables du réchauffement
climatique et ça c'est quelque chose
d'une autre dimension à résoudre septo
vers là qu'il faut s'orienter et puis
mettre en place oui des zones de
protection spéciale
pour les espèces vous avez le sentiment
que
les populations sont suffisamment
sensibilisés à la question des des
espèces marines ou des espèces tout
simplement en voie d'extinction
c'est quelque chose qui a
considérablement évolué je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il ya un très large
public est sensibilisé à ces
problématiques là et il ya pas mal
d'établissements qui jouent leur rôle
notamment
les parcs zoologiques les aquariums les
gestionnaires de sites protégés les
associations qui travaillent
sur ces espèces quelle qu'elle soit
d'ailleurs même un gros travail de
sensibilisation et d'éducation des
publics c'est ce qu'on fait ici
océanopolis
au service de médiation scientifique qui
propose des ateliers qui très impliquée
aussi sur le contenu du circuit de
visite et donc oui mais il ya encore
beaucoup de travail à faire il faut
continuer ce qui a été menée depuis une
vingtaine d'années je veux dire
complètement
l'homme fait partie de cet environnement
et
l'homme a pris un peu le dessus sur son
environnement là un peu déséquilibré ou
le voir et mellon a tout à fait sa place
et forclum corrige un peu ses erreurs de
manière à ce que on retrouve un
équilibre qui permettent à tout le monde
d'avoir sa place dans notre planète sami
hassani merci d'avoir des briefs un
documentaire avec nous merci à vous
c'est la fin du débrief du dock une
émission que nous vous invitons à
retrouver sur notre site internet rt
france point tv très bonne journée à
tous merci de nous avoir suivis
[Musique]